think the work-life balance thing is
nonsense it kind of implies that work is
suffering and life is relief and that
just means you're in a bad situation to
begin with and you need to get out of
that situation where you control your
own life
[Music]
i think i think a lot of people you know
i've definitely heard that sort of like
that i you know the only i i don't i
like playing video games all day long
how do i make well obviously
twitch so there's a pretty easy answer
to that one if that really is your
answer but i think most most people um
yeah i i do think even if you
i think basically i think instead of
thinking about it like work-life balance
i think the work thing throws everyone
off i think i think about it personally
like creation versus consumption or like
contribution versus consumption and i
think everybody even the people who
consume
generally you find that you like a
certain kind of art or a movie or book
uh or you like working out or whatever
and like i think it's figuring out how
do you turn this into oh you know how
can you do this thing but but instead of
consuming the thing as your relationship
with it you are able to create value and
you're able to contribute to other
people in this in this you know in this
vertical or this dimension
yeah and on the work life balance thing
if
if you feel the need i mean not to get
myself in trouble but if you feel like
you need to pursue work-life balance you
are not in a work that is going to lead
to great creative outcomes or building
this sort of business
like i mean
you you it's definitely something you're
obsessed with right i can't imagine
wanting to sit around and watch a
netflix series instead of thinking more
about the stuff that i'm working on or
something i'm doing and it just seems
like such a such a bizarre waste of time
to me and that's not to say that if
you're watching netflix that's a bad
thing or that you like some people want
to live a different kind of life and
that's fine i'm not saying anything
about that but this particular like
we talk about authenticity talk about
being like mastering something like you
don't
you obsess about it it's like your life
and i i just had this moment last week
where i had an unbelievably busy week i
got to friday night and i was like so
pleased i was so satisfied just because
i had felt like you've been such a great
week i made progress in lots of places
and that my life felt very very
imbalanced at that particular moment in
time
since ben is about to get cancelled i'll
get cancelled with him too
i agree i think the work-life balance
thing is nonsense it kind of implies
that work is suffering and life is
relief and that just means you're in a
bad situation to begin with and you need
to get out of that situation where you
control your own life i've been as
guilty as anyone watching netflix and
playing video games but that was
escapism from suffering and once i sort
of aligned my life with doing what i
wanted to do
then i just did that for fun and then
when i don't want to do that anymore i
don't need to do
high
high
mental or high cognition activities like
playing video games i can just go for a
walk or i can hang out with my friends
or i can hang out with my kids and it's
just as fulfilling
so
you your work should be fun it takes
just as much effort to do well at a
video game as it does to start a company
somebody on the internet used a phrase
that really stuck with me i think it
goes by illimitable band or something
one of these uh inspiration accounts but
he said that
he said that video games are shadow
careers and when i read that
at that moment i knew video games were
leaving my life because it was
absolutely spot on right i was building
a career except i was building a career
in some fake land some fake game where
the rules would change or some 12 year
old would come along and crush me the
next week and i saw it for what it was
it was a shadow career because i wasn't
putting that same effort into my main
career because my main career didn't
really line up with what i wanted to do
and that's why i knew it needs to make a
change
so don't waste your life in these shadow
careers even even if you find yourself
craving holidays that means that you're
not enjoying every day that you're sort
of like robbing yourself of your of what
should be a pretty good day
even like i don't know this is an
extreme example but you eventually want
to get to a point where you don't look
down on mondays you don't you don't
dread mondays mondays are no worse or
better than any other day
and so you that means that kind of
getting away from this idea of work-life
balance it's rather getting into a mode
of work where that is your life and this
fulfilling it's good work you enjoy it
you have to align again to use the old
robert frost phrase uh align your
vocation and your application
yeah and not to double down on getting
cancelled but uh you know it's easy to
look at you know today you know deval
and i are doing well and like oh it's
easy for you to say
but like i started strategy while
working another full-time job and and
and what i mean by that is i found it
like this is the part where it actually
it does pay off to do something you love
i love tech i love thinking about tech i
love writing about tech and so it was
actually a form like
by work-life balance my work was kind of
drudgerious but my life was actually
what i was really obsessed about and so
that was a place where i was able to
align the idea of doing what i loved in
my free time and it was able to
transform in the wrong my work i believe
i feel very very fortunate about that
but this isn't an incompatible idea
where if your work is drudgerus that's
actually all the more opportunity to
figure out what it is you love because
if you love it you're not going to feel
like oh now i'm doing two jobs you're
like oh i have my work during the day
and now i get to go home and do the
stuff that i'm excited about that's
actually a an indicator of something
that you you might be worth spending
more time on what has to be understood
is that where greatness comes from
it's a very murky affair
it is non-linear
it is unpredictable
perhaps nature and the universe set it
up this way
that
you have to jump in
and once you jump in the soup
and you're being bombarded through all
sides and you live in confusion and you
have no idea which way is up
if the obsession is there
then what happens is through some
messy process
you find a way you see light at the end
of the tunnel you forge a path through
the jungle
that was not done according to a how you
were flailing the entire time
so there was no how to flail
when you come out through the tunnel and
someone asks you how you did it you have
no idea
the thing that's almost laughable is
when you ask a great athlete can you
show me how you did that they won't come
out and say i have no idea
they will provide you with some
semblance of an answer which is a
non-answer and what they will do is
because there's a gun point to their
head and their backs against a wall
they will create the highlights
when the human being who watches that
follows the highlights he misses and the
reason that he misses is because it's
all the small things
i've found business biographies to be
useless for building a great business
they're good for inspiration i can read
steve jobs bio and be inspired but i
can't be steve jobs and if i want to be
amazing at something then i have to find
my own way there for mechanical things
how to's work but when you're trying to
operate at the top of a field or when
you're trying to do something creative
how to's don't work beyond the most
extreme basics when you're first
starting something it is actually a
mechanical endeavor you're just figuring
out how to drive a car but when you're
trying to figure out how to race around
a track faster than anyone else then all
coaches and techniques and prescriptions
have to fall by the wayside and you are
at the edge of the art
[Music]
you